have you ever been fired from a movie I  was fired from ants no kidding  yeah ants that that animated movie why  do they fire you apparently I was I was  bad ant  did you use your own voice or did you  have a funny voice for a name uh I had  my own and then they brought in Sharon  Stone so I was like oh you really did go  like she's you know like old movie star  Dixon what was your aunt voice this  voice that I'm hearing now yeah I guess  they objected to it but what was  upsetting was that they even called me  like the week before they fired me they  called me to tell me how great I was I  thought like was like a setup but I  think they meant it at that time do you  study ants for do you do study not you  do not are you one of those method  actors where you know well I heard that  Sharon Stone lived among ants that's how  she got the part  but you weren't willing to commit to  plot it against me